[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation now last time I was
at a gathering like this talking about
philanthropy I gave away twenty thousand
dollars in cash to the audience to
figure out what to do with that's not
going to happen tonight
but if it was the way to do it would be
make it two million dollars in cash
lock the doors turn off the exit signs
and nobody leaves until we figure out
what to do with it take a little visit
to that frame of thinking and you've got
a window into the new philanthropy I
have this t-shirt on which harkens back
to coevolution days and probably not
everybody can read it it's sort of
relevant it says in a community
regulated only by laws of demand and
supply but protected from open violence
the persons who become rich are
generally speaking industrious resolute
proud covetous prompt methodical
sensible unimaginative insensitive and
ignorant the persons who remain poor are
the entirely foolish the entirely wise
the idle the reckless the humble the
thoughtful the dull the imaginative the
sensitive the well-informed the
improvident the irregularly and
impulsively wicked the clumsy knave the
open thief and the entirely merciful
just and godly person that was said by
written by giant said because he always
spoke a lot John Ruskin in 1860 in
Britain
he was talking about the world he knew
which was the community regulated only
by laws of demand and supply as he
called it he wasn't aware that by then
beginning only in the US West where
there was communities before there were
really cities form of philanthropy was
starting to take shape by the end of
that century people like Richard rel
Rockefellers great-grandfather would
basically invent modern philanthropy as
an American invention and it keeps being
reinvented and the person here to bring
us up-to-date as one who knows more
about it than anybody Catherine Fulton
I've known Stuart for a while now I
didn't know that he was guilty of such
hyperbole it is wonderful to be here
with so many friends that I know are
sitting out there and to take advantage
of Stuart's offer to talk about what
I've learned in the last few years I've
had the privilege starting a gbn a
global business network that Stuart
helped found since about 1998 to do a
lot of work with new philanthropists
building on many years of interest in
the field myself grew up in a wonderful
philanthropic family so I've been
thinking hard about philanthropy for a
long time and it's going to be great fun
to share the stage with Larry and with
Richard what we're going to do is I'm
going to speak a little bit I get to ask
them a question first and then they're
going to ask me questions and we're
going to take your questions and have a
have an exchange I do want to start with
Stuart who has had such a powerful
impact on me both directly and
indirectly for reasons that he will know
and I want to start with one of my
favorite quotes from him for the
purposes of tonight I did burst out
laughing when I read this in the clock
and along now
about a week ago when he said the great
problem with the futures that we die
there and you know made me realize that
the long nail seminars most of them are
have not been about things that are
personal and that this is a night where
we can open some new terrain because
ultimately a Stuart suggests it's
difficult to get serious about long-term
responsibility unless it gets personal
tonight is about what it is that normal
mortal individuals using the resources
at our disposal can do to look out for
the future it's about one of the most
fascinating stories I think on the
planet today which is about the new
philanthropy and it's about the battle
for the soul and the direction of the
new philanthropy and yes it's about Bill
Gates and Larry brilliant and Bill
Clinton and a lot of celebrity P
that many of you have heard of but I
also want to suggest that it's about all
of us for reasons that I hope will be
clear by the time that we finished
tonight in order to talk about the new
philanthropy though we have to first
talk about philanthropy which is of
course not at all new the dictionary
definition talk it talks about love of
humankind and you will notice that it
doesn't talk about money at all one of
the things that's interesting about
philanthropy and and something I want to
encourage you to think about is that
philanthropy is can be about giving of
your time it can be giving about giving
of knowledge it can be about know-how
can be about sharing your networks as
well as money and in many many cultures
of course the word philanthropy is would
never be used it's just giving and it's
as old as humankind now of course we are
in an era when philanthropy is being
reinvented and it is a new era and that
is not hype the news not the deeper news
of course is the is the philanthropy
that's taking place and is it is on many
magazine covers and getting a lot of
attention in the in the media and and
what I want to do is talk to you about
some of the reasons that that new
philanthropy is getting created some of
the things that I think are most
interesting about it for a bit and and
talk about the need for it and talk
about what what it will take for that
philanthropy to be great because the
fact that it's happening so far does not
mean that it's actually going to make a
lot of difference so the the place that
I want to start is to sort of say why
why is it that we are in this new era
what's interesting is if you look
philanthropy was modern philanthropy was
invented in the United States a hundred
years ago and if you look at any of
these factors up here the new technology
and new money and and the sort of new
zeitgeist in the in terms of the
intellectual ideas and the culture new
leaders new rules and new tax laws that
kind of thing what's amazing about today
is that all of these things are true any
one of them could change and has changed
philanthropy in the past they were 200
years
many of them and their true again and we
are at a real turning point for
philanthropy and what I think it's
really important to understand is that
the story is just beginning it's it's
really very very new and as I say I want
to tell you about some of the things
that I think are most most interesting
from the body of work that my colleagues
Andrew Blau and capable Kasper and I
have done the the first thing to draw
your attention to is is in fact the the
most wealthy right and that is of course
a change we know is underway for a lot
of reasons if you look at this charts
back in 1982 there were 13 billionaires
in the Forbes 400 there were just in the
most recent cover last week last month
400 when I first started essentially
working and covering the future
philanthropy there were half that many
and that was in 1998 and and it goes
beyond that between 2000 and 2004 the
number of households with a net worth of
a hundred million or more 100 million or
more in the u.s. rose from 7,000 to
10,000 and just the last those three
years now what that means is that large
philanthropy philanthropy that is done
often in institutions or in large gifts
is is growing and you can and and what
is important is that a lot of that money
is still in the sidelines as Warren
Buffett was until very recently and it's
on the sidelines it's waiting it's
watching it hasn't come in and if even
10% of those people start great new
foundations philanthropy will be face of
philanthropy will be extraordinarily
changed in this country and in the world
it's already starting this is the growth
in large foundations in the US and just
look what's happened just just very
recently there are now 50 US foundations
with assets of a billion dollars 30 of
them give away a hundred million dollars
each year the Gates Foundation alone
gives away 1.5 billion and is on its way
by 2009 to giving away 3 billion a year
that means the Gates Foundation will
give away 10% of all foundation giving
in the US there's never been private
giving on this scale before now you can
argue that it may not be a good thing
and many people do maybe an excuse for
government to withdraw in some ways but
it's nevertheless is happening and it's
also a global phenomenon these were just
just a smattering of a map of
millionaire's across the world the
richest person of Chinese descent the
Hong Kong billionaire li kai-shing just
announced a six billion dollar donation
to his private foundation and that's a
third only a third of his wealth those
announcements are coming around the
world now so what's happening is a shift
from east to west in u.s. philanthropy
its dispersing across the world it's not
all happening in foundations and so the
scale of it is is really is really quite
something
so what's even more interesting is where
the money is coming from if you just
look at this as so this is some work
with some research we did recently 1957
when Fortune magazine this is from
historian Fortune magazine on well owned
wealthy in the United States more than
half of the richest people in the
country had their wealth from
inheritance and oil was the next and
you'll notice that high-tech and finance
there was essentially none if you
fast-forward to 8 1985 it starts to
change but look at this now in 19 2005
inheritance was down to 7% this is again
in the Forbes 400 oil is 3% but high
tech is up to 13% and finance at 17% of
the great fortunes there's also a we
also have some very interesting charts
on age because of course the people are
getting younger and that's you know part
of the sort of structural shift in the
knowledge economy but what's interesting
about that is the the change in the
zeitgeist that then happens and the sort
of bringing the tech culture to
philanthropy which I think through the
amid yars and through Google is one of
the most obvious places that's happening
the what what happens is that if you
think about some of the aspects of
high-tech culture this sort of speed the
rapid prototyping the learning-by-doing
thinking big the power of the individual
the the the the ability to quantify and
measure things often and that's true in
finance as well these things are all
coming in to philanthropy and what's
fascinating to watch is how they are
they're correcting against the old
philanthropy many of the things of the
old philanthropy in New York and in some
ways they may be trying maybe starting
to overcorrect which may be something we
may want to talk about but it's
fascinating to watch what's happening it
is a significant shift the other thing
that's happening is is the use of
markets and investing not just
philanthropy this is a foreign that
skull foundation holds Jeffrey Scholl
who was one of the the first president
of eBay foundation his works on social
entrepreneurship and this was this year
they worked on looking at social capital
markets there are lots of people
starting to talk about think about a
marketplace for the capital that's in
search of doing good not just
philanthropy but also investment capital
and what's happening is a range of money
from subsidized through loans through
investments for a range of purposes and
a lot of experimentation starting to go
on there and then I believe I saw David
banks help David banks with that story
for The Wall Street Journal he's out
there in the audience on giving giving
while living is a very interesting thing
that's also changing got people who are
younger they want to give the money
while they're away it's not about
setting something up in perpetuity and a
very interesting question for for the
long now and for long term
responsibilities is is it better to give
to an urgent problem today and try to
fix something that could do damage the
long term or is it better to set up a
long term institution that will be there
interestingly enough George Soros I
always said he would give all this money
away in his lifetime as did john d
rockefeller by the way and he's just
recently changed his mind it hasn't
gotten much publicity he's decided that
he's going to have his foundations go in
perpetuity and he's going to leave it
open to what they do
he says he wants them to be able to be
entrepreneurial and he can't possibly
know what's going to be needed after he
dies so it's a it's a it's an
interesting an interesting shift for for
George I think all of this is
interesting but I have to tell you I
don't think it's nearly as interesting
as the philanthropy for the rest of us
most and actually I forgot I wanted to
say something about the Rockefeller
Foundation the old foundations there's
the new players but the old players are
also changing Rockefeller Foundation's
almost a hundred years old
is completely revamping itself
influenced not just by the new
philanthropy but by the changes in the
world and and they are now partnering in
big ways with the Gates Foundation and
others so I think you're gonna see
changes in the new big philanthropy
we're also going to see changes in the
old philanthropy that we need to not
lose sight of and then what what I was
going to say is I think all of that
could actually be less important than
the philanthropy for the rest of us most
giving is from individuals most people
don't realize that because so much
attention goes to the big institutions
three-quarters of the giving comes from
individuals in and and we the the and I
think this is kind of the Trojan horse
really of the changes in philanthropy
most of this money of course goes where
to religious institutions but that's
dropping the money that's going to
universities and colleges and schools is
flat arts institutions are starting to
struggle more and so there's some
interesting there's some interesting
shifts here let's look at what's at
what's happening there's always been a
hundred years ago in philanthropy got
got changed and reinvented with
invention of the foundation form and it
there was also the community foundation
was invented and we've done a number a
lot of work at monitor and gbn about
Community Foundation's as well which we
think of it as as aggregated giving
putting putting a lot of smaller
donations together there's a tremendous
amount of potential in in this there's
700 Community Foundation's in America
now they're 1,500 around the world the
World Bank has a program of starting of
helping to start these around the world
and
there are Mexican town associations that
note just raise you know send money back
to their families but also send money to
build schools in in towns middle-class
and working-class people are much more
generous actually than wealthy people
not in the amount they give but in the
percentage of what they give and so when
you put all that money together it's
actually it actually adds up to to a lot
and then if you move it forward and you
add the and you add some other things to
it it gets very interesting these are
the people that I'm most interested in
in philanthropy today I think of them as
the people who are reorganizing
philanthropy they're the community
foundations of the future they're the
people who raise smaller amounts of
money or the people who give wealthy
people an alternative to a private
foundation acumen fund is is a venture
is a venture fund that raises money
raises philanthropic money and adds a
lot of business intelligence to it and
invest it in businesses in in the
developing world and at a moment when
you need that you need that patient
capital just like Mohammad Yunus needed
it for Grameen Bank
you know foundations put tens of
millions of dollars into microfinance
before it became a real business and
that's that's acumen new profit is is
leading the way for a whole generation
of social entrepreneurs in America
helping them go from smaller
organizations to larger organizations
Social Venture Partners I think has
three or four hundred people in coming
together in in Seattle the women's
funding network and and Hispanics in
philanthropy there are a number of these
groups what they do is is raise money
from a lot of people and put it together
against a single goal so you you begin
to get over the problem of lots of small
donations that don't add up to things
and what it means is that somebody like
me who doesn't have time to do a lot of
work on what I should give to and I just
am opening a lot of things saying where
should I give to this and that it gives
me a way to outsource the strategy have
an impact larger impact without having
to you know be part of some large
institution these guys are I think I
think of these as the mutual funds of
philanthropy of the future you know it's
just like you would never
many people would not try to pick stocks
why would you try to pick you know
individual organizations to give to so
what you have is a kind of venture
capital private equity capital and
mutual funds that are essentially
developing philanthropy that I think
will reorganize the philanthropy of a
lot of individuals and then there's
online giving which is growing very
rapidly Network forget good one of the
portals and online in in in it
facilitates online giving just past a
hundred million mark for giving and and
I think again if you add technology to
this notion of the brokers who are
reorganizing things what you get is
these new philanthropic marketplaces
DonorsChoose is a place that allows
people in schools to say they need
something in school and the donor to go
straight to the you know essentially
disintermediated giving their there and
then there are these marketplaces that
are starting to be in India and
Argentina and South Africa that use
online and offline as a way again I
think of organizing money and being the
Community Foundation's of the future so
I'll make a prediction Stuart I'm not
sure they'll take me up for it as a bet
but I think that the large one of the
largest foundations into in 2020 won't
be have been started by a rich person so
open source philanthropic portal tops 1
billion and gifts headline in 2020 so a
you know you we've got the new
philanthropist who have a lot of money
and they're going to have a lot of
impact we have the old philanthropists
who are changing and who are changing
we're feeling the pressure the Ford
Foundation is about to have a new
president etc and then we have the
philanthropy of the rest of us and one
one that I am particularly interested in
is given diya and I think perhaps the
the organization that that could be the
one I just talked about in 2020 is given
to you this is their image this is their
model that of having a charity exchange
in the middle and building an entire
civil society infrastructure around it
to build a culture of giving in one of
the largest countries in the world
they're just getting started and I think
that that they're they're
entrepreneurial and they're going to
really make
difference so the philanthropy is this
story of the newness if you just kind of
step I can say so what really is new I
created this little picture for myself
when I started doing this work of sort
of looking at so what was the
philanthropy of 10,000 years ago was
this it was local it was face to face it
was short-term it was need that people
had right there face to face that people
helped each other out and if you move
through time and you look at the changes
in the economy and things moving people
people and changes in technology and be
able to move outward into regions and
nations and you look at the types of
institutions that that came into being
of course patronage was a big was a
charity and patronage were a big part of
philanthropy especially for art and then
we had the invention of organized
philanthropy the the business of
beneficence was what john d rockefeller
called it about a hundred years ago and
what's happened now it's just added
everything on there now in a knowledge
economy it's all global it's really
about it's increasingly about networks
that are technology enabled that that I
think make make a lot of things possible
it's about whoever the most effective
actor is which isn't necessarily the
nonprofit and it's charity organized
philanthropy and social investing so
it's much more complex
the choices are are much are much
greater
I think what's what's interesting to
think about here is that philanthropy
for the long term is a modern creation
it may even be an unnatural act you know
in the sense that you know people give
give to what the need is that you see in
front of you
that's what charity is but philanthropy
for the longer term that engages people
half a world away is something modern
and again arguably not natural so these
are some of the elements of promise of
this that's the system that is emerging
that builds on all the errors before it
and and so you asked so what so what
well once so what is of course the
problems are so much larger than the
philanthropy all these numbers seem
really big until you talk to the patty
Stonesifer from gates and she'll tell
you that actually they spend four in a
million dollars on trying to get kids
ready for college but the state of
California spends 40 billion so our
monies are a drop in the bucket we could
spend down the endowment in one year and
not have improved education just in the
state of California most people who get
into philanthropy in any big way realize
this very quickly that it seems big and
it seems great it's very exciting but
actually it's it's small so so we have
to keep that in mind and then the other
problem of course is that the problems
are growing as fast as these endowments
and and philanthropies are or faster I
laughed out loud when I saw this cartoon
in The New Yorker a couple weeks ago it
says good morning you better sit down
with the guy going in watching the TV
and it's it's you know it is a very dark
time in many ways and my friend Larry
brilliant gives it absolutely wonderful
talk about the crises of our time that
all of us need to pay attention to and
philanthropy you know class P can't take
the role of government and it's not
doesn't have a scale of business but
there but there is a role for it and I
would think arguably at this moment in
the history of our civilization it's not
just a nice to have it's a must have and
that's where you get into the real
deeper news and I want to do that by
invoking Stewart again and one of the
models that many of you may have seen
that the long now foundation uses in the
clock of the long now and Stewart's book
he calls it the the pace layering and
it's about the different layers of
civilization and that that change at
different paces so you have fashion
changes the fastest you have markets the
change and and a little bit faster on a
quarterly basis you get the the
infrastructure the the things that the
pipes the schools
the things that makes make society work
governance culture nature each of them
changes at a different pace so the the
fast gets the attention Stuart points
out the slow has all the power the whole
combines of learning with continent
continuity and but and what that means
is that when civilizations get a shock
then there's a there's a balancing that
there's a way to absorb them we're in
the midst of one of those shocks today I
don't think there's any question about
it and it's planet-wide
and slowly I think the nature of that is
that the is that the the layers at the
top and Kevin Kelley has also pointed at
their salaries their disruptive power is
so great they can now destroy our future
the top layers can destroy culture in
nature and they're doing so and
infrastructure and governance aren't
doing their job very well New Yorker
piece recently on water was about a
failure of infrastructure facilitated by
a failure of governance and there's much
of that all around the world it's the
job of the infrastructure and the
governance to represent the future to
the present to invest in making people
healthy and educating them protecting
them from random or intentional violence
investing in the basic science that will
improve life for all to stand up to the
abuse of power and to create new
solutions now a very interesting thing
has happened is that the social sector
supported by philanthropy has taken up
the work of making sure that
civilization is healthy it's slowly
becoming a new kind of infrastructure
and governance the it's stepping into
the vacuum in the middle of this
framework and looking out for the future
and this is very good news and let's
just give you a couple of examples it
may well be that Bill Clinton exercises
more leadership in post of his
presidency than he did as president he
said something about how kind of present
he was but it's it's it's about the
leadership is now coming from different
places and there's a an interesting
thing I just
learned this week is that Mo Ibrahim who
is the uk-based mobile phone
entrepreneur born in Egypt has has just
announced a five million dollar prize
aimed at fighting corruption that's
richer than the Nobel Prize and and what
he wants to do is is have Harvard rate
the governance of fifty three African
countries so that when a president
leaves if he served his country well and
he passes power to a democratic
democratically to a successor he can
actually prize and pay for his life and
not have to be corrupt it's a you know
it's an interesting idea it's a private
philanthropist Singh nobody else is
stepping up I'm going to an interesting
another interesting example is George
Soros in 2002 started something called
the publish what you pay campaign there
now three hundred NGOs worldwide
involved in this this is the counter the
resource curse the repressed the the
repressive corrupt governments and so
many poor but natural resource rich
countries and so what what this is to do
is to get is a campaign to get oil and
mining companies to disclose all the
payments they make to governments so
it's a transparency play that once those
are disclosed you can add them all up
you can actually see the payments that
are going to any government that gives
it in a tool to civil society and
citizens to to battle the battle of
government so what you see here is
private citizens stepping up to play the
role of infrastructure and and
government so this is happening all over
the place you know it's an explosion in
in civil society these numbers are
between 1980 and 2000 a number of
nonprofits in Brazil went from less than
5,000 to more than a million in this
country the nonprofit sector employs
more people than the federal government
50 state governments combined Lester
Salamon who's one of the great scholars
of this field you know basically says
that citizen organizations in this era
is important as the rise of the
nation-state in the in the 19th century
the last time that we counted this and
we have a candidate for a little bit
there were a hundred and nineteen new
nonprofits and eleven new foundation
started in the US every day if you want
to know why it's so hard to raise money
it's because there are more nonprofits
being started than there are new
foundations the numbers look like this I
mean it's just going up and up and up
and up and the good news is that people
are stepping up to the challenge and the
this is a very interesting the Grameen
Bank winning a Nobel Prize made us take
a check at this look at what's happened
to the number of Nobel Prize winners who
are NGOs and in the last hundred years
in the last ten years four of them have
been NGOs the Campaign to Ban Landmines
and Doctors Without Borders
Longoria mitai and the green belt
movement I know the Grameen Bank
so philanthropy is a critical part of
this emerging system of problem solving
and it's an absolutely critical lever in
any system to have better solutions and
again back at you Stewart I love this
quote of Stewart's nobody can save the
world but any of us can help set in
motion a self saving world and I would
submit that that is the role of
philanthropy and that is the role that
it's stepping up to today it may well be
that long-term thinking is is is
difficult and rare but if our
civilization survives another ten
thousand years it may be in part because
civil society and philanthropy backing
it has really stepped up so if I'm if my
interpretation of Stuart's framework has
any validity validity we've never had a
greater need for philanthropy it's an
urgent requirement of our civilization
and it's it may be that it's an urgent
requirement because the window open to
deal with the problem I described here
of the destruction of culture in nature
won't be open forever so there's a very
interesting question about what is
long-term responsibility is doing
something urgently now
or is it setting up things in perpetuity
now what I want to do is shift gears for
a second I've talked about the promise
of a new philanthropy I've talked about
the the need for it and you know but the
truth is of course most philanthropy
isn't doesn't do this most philanthropy
is is not great philanthropy so what is
it going to take to to change things and
for the better and I want to share a few
thoughts with you the body of work that
we've done is is is there it's all in
the web and you can pick up a copy of
our of our book outside but I want I
want to talk about what it will take for
for view to be a hopeful one and rather
than a cynical and discouraging one I do
feel hopeful that both the quality and
quantity of philanthropy is going to
grow in the next year and then one day
we will look back on this time as a time
where there was a significant shift and
how people used resources imaginatively
and against the biggest issues of our
time I feel hopeful about this and I
want to speak more personally about it
again having said that the long now is
about being personal because it's going
to be because it depends on all of us
taking responsibility not just the
people who are famous and I believe
today there's a tremendous hunger for
this everywhere I go in the world inside
companies that that we work with inside
so many young people coming out of
college and graduate school people who
are nearing the end of the careers that
they're in who want to who want to now
make a more significant contribution
there's there's such hunger everywhere
and it won't it's not going to be about
whether they're up to the challenge of
this it's about whether we're all up to
it there is no such thing as
philanthropy there are only mortal
fallible individuals who give
because of course philanthropy is
entirely a voluntary act can't tell
anybody else what to do with their
philanthropy they can only tell
themselves it happens it happens inside
so the choices ahead are personal and
their individual and importantly there
are no wrong choices because they come
from inside people so what I want to
tell you just just for a couple of
minutes is is what I think the questions
that need to be asked are of to do great
philanthropy whether it's the whether it
takes place at the level of the Gates
Foundation or when I go to my kitchen
table to write my checks in December the
and when I said I think that there's a
battle for the soul and direction of new
of the new philanthropy I think this is
what it's about
so the first question is a question
about direction and it's about what what
challenges are we taking on are they
just the ones that matter to us
personally the school that we went to
the people that we know the community
that we came from or have we enlarged a
circle of our empathy beyond that this
is a map that I use for myself and I
find it really helpful to literally just
map what I give to the most philanthropy
is in the upper right corner it's
personal local regional it's your church
unity your school it's shorter term or
responsive the people down here in this
corner in the in the bottom left-hand
corner who are in another country who
are trying to change something
fundamental can't find me they can't ask
me for money and so one of the things
that I do is challenge myself to find
things to go and seek out against what I
think the problems are rather than just
doing the easy thing of giving what what
comes to me that means that decision
making philanthropy has to be connected
to knowledge and it isn't often the
people who have the resources
make the decisions but but without
necessarily being connected to the
people who have on the ground who have
the knowledge about what the real need
is so in order for there to be a new
direction we have to expand this circle
of empathy and I think that's one of the
things that's been most impressive about
Bill Gates whatever else you want to say
about him he went for Miss philanthropy
being about computers in schools which
is something that he knew to global
public health and that's that's been
very impressive and a lot depends on how
many other people how many of the new
philanthropists the new large givers as
well as the rest of us do the same the
how the what question is intimately
related to the second question which is
the how question and this is where I
believe there's a battle of a different
kind going on that I think is more
important even more important than the
what it's about strategy and it's about
soul because you can try to do great
things that are important and
significant and fail miserably at doing
them if you're not both smart and wise
about how you do them so the question is
will Volant through P be smart and wise
as well as full of good intentions first
the smart part social change is not like
business as anybody here who's been
involved in it knows it's much harder
and it takes a very long time and the
problems do with the efforts of even the
largest actors it's not about
competition it's about cooperation for
the long term it's about building
collective will to deal with the worst
challenges that we face we need the best
talent in the world with the appropriate
resources to the task arrayed against
problems for a very long time the
problems that arrived didn't arrive
quickly they won't go away quickly and
Danny Hillis actually again associated
with along now pointed out something
brilliant that the problems are
impossible to think about if you think
about them in two years time frames but
if you think about solving something in
a 50 year time frame it changes
everything
now the problem of course is that what
I've just described very rarely happens
in philanthropy you see a lot of three
to five year initiatives and then people
get bored and go to the next new thing
you see funders tired of support tiring
of supporting the same institutions and
all of us you know writing a check the
same year every year after the same
thing instead of rewarding success
moving to the next thing you see people
setting ambitious goals and then setting
a budget that's completely insufficient
to achieve those goals this is the thing
that drives me the most crazy so people
you know a great big goal and then say
well you know here's a hundred thousand
dollars to do it or five hundred
thousand dollars to do it or whatever
you see people insisting that their
funds be used for direct service and
this is a particular disease of the new
philanthropy while ignoring all the
infrastructure and overhead that is
necessary to provide that service so I
just want my money to go to the people
who need it and you see funders looking
with disdain at the efforts under way
and saying we can do this better
ourselves even when they're starting
from scratch and have absolutely no
knowledge and have made little effort to
understand who the other players really
are including the other funders so this
is the opposite really of the things
that are needed it's it's as though
almost people lose their brains when
they leave the business where they made
the money and come over to do
philanthropy so a lot depends on whether
the new philanthropy gets smart which
means that it refuses to adopt the
habits of the old philanthropy and the
old philanthropy is fragmented and short
term the new philanthropy needs to be
connected and patient one of the most
hopeful signs again at the Gates
Foundation eighty-five percent of their
funding and global public health is in
partnership they got that really quickly
and indeed Buffett's gift itself is a
great example of that
I think of combining efforts not
splitting them up ironically the best
example of this kind of philanthropy in
the past generation was from
conservative foundations this is a
National Center for Responsive
philanthropy study of seventy-nine
conservative foundations who were
focused and had a common agenda to
change the
basically the the ideology of the
country and they succeeded
they created an infrastructure of ideas
and the means of communicating them they
build strong institutions through long
term investments that they made over
decades and they worked in concert with
each other on a common agenda
it was stunning the impact that they had
so this quote is however what is
happening I think in in some of the
areas of new philanthropy I'm gonna read
it out loud I it's going to take more
than smart strategies to to make a
difference
and I I ran across a man a couple of
weeks ago who was working at one of the
large new economy foundations and he was
just pulling his hair out
he said we have lots of smart people but
very little wisdom we have no deep
contextual understanding and experience
we often are isolated from the messy
reality of the world political and
social and human we have no tolerance
for ambiguity when he said this it
crystallized for me that how much I
believe that the success of the new
philanthropy is going to come down to
how quickly people learn Stuart once
wrote a book on how buildings learn I
think we're going to have to watch how
philanthropist learn it's it rang true
for me and it made me think to put this
in actually starker terms imagine for a
second if the civil rights movement were
underway today and it one of the great
enduring achievements of the 20th
century in America think about this
ragtag bunch of people they wouldn't be
funded by the many of today's new
philanthropists they didn't have a
business plan or performance metrics
their strategy was improvised month to
month their relationships were messy
with each other and the whole thing was
pretty chaotic if you've ever read
Taylor branch's books it's just stunning
how chaotic it was there was no plan
batting on them took a leap of faith and
it took caring and it took it believing
in them for a very long time somebody
paid for those buses that people went to
the
March on Washington in right there were
some philanthropist who did that but
there's a there's a zeitgeist today and
in the new philanthropy that I think has
a ways to go in terms of of wisdom great
philanthropy is a rare combination
risk-taking empathy stamina and humility
I think that's a pretty good definition
of wisdom I think there's a reason to be
hopeful there are signs of rapid
learning happening and wisdom being
acquired but as my friend Sam keen puts
it wisdom is never available on the
second-hand market that Elise's advice
I've been giving myself for 25 years so
what in the end is great philanthropy
and service of the long now it's service
of long term responsibility I can do no
better than share these words from
Martin Luther King I'm a southerner so
you have to forgive all the civil rights
stuff changed my life in a lot of ways
when Luther King was not talking about
philanthropy when he spoke in 1967 and a
famous speech called where do we go from
here but he did talk about power and
here's what he said
now power properly understood is nothing
but the ability to achieve purpose and
one of the great problems of history is
that the concepts of love and power have
usually been contrasted as opposites
polar opposites so that love is
identified with a resignation of power
and power with a denial of love what is
needed is a realization that power
without love is reckless and abusive and
love without power is sentimental and
anemic
power at its best is love implementing
the demands of justice and justice at
its best is power correcting everything
that stands against love
I couldn't just put that up and not
talked at all so I've talked about the
promise of the new philanthropy all the
changes that are underway the size of it
the scope of it the type of it talked
about the need for it and I've talked
about some of the choices about the what
and how that need to be made for it to
fulfill its promise because it's
entirely possible that the new
philanthropy will fail to live up to the
legacy to the legacy that it could leave
I don't believe that that's going to be
the case I've met too many of the
wonderful people and we're about to meet
some some of them on the stage who are
leading the way but but the advice I
would give adds up to it's pretty simple
it's and it's a wish not a bat for the
new philanthropy and for all of us to
pick at least one difficult complex
thing or a great organization
stick with it support it for a long time
have enough humility to accelerate our
learning in the face of great complexity
and join with others in doing it
cooperatively but these choices about
what to do and how to do it are being
made by tens of thousands of people all
over the world today that's why those
numbers of NGOs are going up and they're
being made by every person in this room
each choice does matter because they are
cumulative and someone sitting here and
this is something I will predict someone
sitting here is going to do something
quite extraordinary
that you've not thought of yet that's
going to change the world and maybe more
than a few someone's because a better
world is never going to be created from
the top down with some master plan it's
going to be you only emerge from the
bottom up from the choices of creative
and committed people and these choices
can now be connected in ways that were
never before possible in human history
that's the reason I have so much hope so
thank you very much
[Applause]
so I think Larry and Richard are gonna
come up here as the screen gonna come up
thank you
so um I promised them Stewart said um I
got to get my dominatrix going here he
said Katherine we worked for you two
here tonight so he told me that I could
start by asking these guys a question
first and I want to ask them about what
they've learned and Richard you were
born with the land to be in your
bloodstream and but you've had quite an
extraordinary life yourself been
involved with a number of organizations
and you're now chair of the Rockefeller
Brothers fund and I'm just really
curious what do you know now that you
didn't know when you were 25 about how
to do this philanthropy game I think I
may have learned as much tonight already
as I learned in the rest of the time
since I was 25 one of the things about
growing up in the Rockefeller family is
that it really is the water that you
swim in and for a long time I think you
can't see it it's just there's the
culture of my family for whatever reason
Stewart asked me not that long ago why
is it and other people have asked me why
is it the Rockefellers stay involved
with philanthropy and I don't have a
very good answer for it I don't know
other than that we had strong role
models and it's just what my my father
is David Rockefeller he was involved
with it his entire life and we were
expected to be and I don't know we just
we are somebody said it's in the DNA but
I know that I got pretty diluted DNA
from John I'm the fourth generation Dan
from John Dee so it can't just be that
so one thing I would say is that I've
moved from a state of unreflecting Ness
about philanthropy
probably that was where I was at age 25
through a number of experiences to a
position where I really think about it
quite a lot and I have to say that that
complicates my life in some ways
philanthropy when you just take it for
granted that you're going to inherit
some money and then you're gonna give it
away youyou certainly the the precepts
that I grew up with about trying to
address root causes that was my
great-grandfather's word for it and we
call it strategic philanthropy now that
that's a good thing and it's also good
to give money for charity in your local
community but that there is a continuum
from charity to strategic philanthropy
and you should think about where you are
on that those you know that that came
with with the inheritance in a sense
Richard yes request that hitters to have
the mic up a little closer to you no
sorry it's just a little better sound
thanks yep put ears up in the back if
you can't hear me okay have you heard
what I've said so far oh good I don't
want to start over again anyway so
there's a lot of reflection has come
first through you mentioned a threshold
foundation or I had a discussion about
it earlier and I bit was involved with
that
quite early on and it one of the things
that that engagement taught me a group
of people called the donuts because it's
a bunch of nuts with dough we did
exercises in that group about two-thirds
of us had inherited wealth and about
one-third had made their own money and
there was a huge divide there as you
might imagine but we all were encouraged
to really think about that and think and
feel about that experience what the
emotional impact of having money of
getting money given to you of giving
away money that made an enormous
difference in my life and taught me that
there are for everybody tremendous
complexes that come with money not the
same for everybody and if you do not
what those complexes are when you start
out to give money you're likely to do
things through projection that really
don't necessarily benefit there they're
dealing with your own neuroses in a
sense rather than benefiting the person
that you're giving the money to so that
was a very valuable lesson another thing
I learned was that some of the the
precepts such as the continuum from
charities to strategic giving don't
actually apply in the real world and
that's good to rethink that from time to
time that realization arose through my
experience with Doctors Without Borders
I've chaired the u.s. Advisory Board of
MF medicine Southmont er MSF in the for
the past 17 years and I loved it from
the start because the people are so
dedicated I'm a physician myself a
family doc and I was in a bunch with a
bunch of people who were doing what we
were all trained to do but those of us
who stay practicing in the u.s. don't
actually get to do it most of the time
we end up being kind of I don't know
functionaries more than real healers so
I loved it from that standpoint but I
was skeptical because from everything I
had learned they were doing kind of
charity care going over and providing
directly for people rather than
addressing root causes since 99 when we
began treating and and particularly
starting in 2001 when MSF began
providing antiretroviral therapy in the
developing world it became clear to me
that there's there are blurred lines in
there that you can provide what looks
like charity care in ways that turn out
to be remarkably strategic so that we're
all the experts in in 1999 right through
about four years ago we're saying it's
stupid to actually treat people with
AIDS
you should what you should do instead is
do prevention because you'll never be
able to afford it you'll never have the
health infrastructure you will develop
resistance that then will come back to
haunt
etc etc well the idealists charity
providers at MSF in a sense said well
the heck with that we cannot function on
the ground pretending to treat these
other conditions but not treat medically
what we're seeing in front of us so the
prices of drugs are too high we're going
to do something about that will will not
accept the assumptions about the
infrastructure we're going to build our
own infrastructure and see what happens
there
and indeed we did that from 99 2000 when
the annual cost of anti retrovirals
around the world was fifteen to
seventeen thousand dollars per person
per year we and other advocates managed
to bring that price down to where it now
is under a hundred and fifty dollars per
person per year for which I take no
credit at all but I love being
associated with the organization that
has helped do that and we've shown that
infrastructure in the developed world
isn't necessary at all in the
underdeveloped in the developing world
and that in fact rates of adherence of
medication regimes throughout Africa and
we have now got about 25 programs are
better than they are in New York about
90% and we do not get the resistance and
we do get cooperation and we're all
prevention efforts I'm going to end with
this I would get to turn this back over
to you prevention efforts had there too
for been pretty much useless people in
developing countries with very high
rates of HIV infection really would not
look at the problem because it seemed so
big and so hopeless and problems that
are too big are just not worth looking
at at all that's the way it feels to
people once we started treating the idea
that there might be hope spread very
rapidly through these first the villages
and then the larger societies and people
since then have been willing to look at
what it takes to do good reasonable
prevention screening and so forth so
what looked like purely treating the
symptom turned out to be essential to
the strategic approach to the entire
problem so I have other things that I've
learned but I think I'll stop there
so Larry been on the job now for what
eight months six can you imagine what it
would be like - what an amazing job in
an opportunity but can you imagine the
number of emails come in there's never
been a more visible I can't get used to
be people could start philanthropy and
be under the radar can you imagine being
Google it's doing your philanthropy you
breathe and the world notices so Larry
what's a question on your mind now after
six months microphone he's got one yeah
well first of all your presentation was
phenomenal yeah
so I did I did one thing really smart
the first phone call that I made when I
was hired was I called her and I said
what do I do now you know it feels like
as I've seen all the old friends here in
the room we know each other from so many
different walks of life but we have all
been here before it really feels like
that that this room the feeling in the
room the people that we know I've sort
of been plucked about it could have been
any one of us here so I'm channeling all
of you and that it feels like that to me
in a way I'm channeling our culture it's
an unusual position because we're in the
midst of a huge cultural war this
election on Tuesday is part of a
cultural war Newt Gingrich said it was a
cultural war
Bill Clinton represented a part of a
cultural war we really are and the new
philanthropy represents a little bit of
the extension of that cultural war and I
I've been thinking since I got in this
job where do you go to find a a guiding
principle of Summum bonum or some kind
of a standard against which you judge
what one does I had the great privilege
of being on a stage with Richard's
cousin Steven Rockefeller two weeks ago
with His Holiness the Dalai Lama and his
cousin is a real philosopher he teaches
philosophy has for 30 years I'm an
amateur philosopher I was an
undergraduate but never made it beyond
undergraduate and we got to ask the
Dalai Lama the questions that you'd all
like to ask him we got to get up on a
stage and I got to say your holiness is
there a hierarchy of suffering
and and if there is should that
hierarchy inform the decisions that we
make in philanthropy and he wasn't
prepped
we've been prepped and he thought about
it and he said yes there's a hierarchy
of suffering and it should inform what
you do in philanthropy because the
person who is on the brink of starving
to death the person whose illness will
take their life away the person who is
the poorest that is the person you
should think about first in your
philanthropy it's the same thing Mahatma
Gandhi said when he was asked by a young
radical can you give me something to
protect me from making a mistake and he
answered yes I can give you a talisman a
magic amulet that will protect you from
ever making a mistake before you act
consider the poorest the most homeless
the most wretched human being that you
have ever seen in your life and ask
yourself will the next act that I am
contemplating benefit that person if it
will you're safe if it won't think again
so I thought all right I'll go back to
philosophy and I'll look at what I
thought was what I thought then were
Maimonides principles of charity and I
don't know how many of you like me
mistakenly thought that the old saw to
give a man of fish is not as high an act
of charity as to teach that man to fish
I know how maybe you thought that that
was part of Maimonides principles of
charities but it's not and so if you
Google give a man
fish you'll find there's 600 charitable
foundations that are named give a man a
fish now it's very interesting because
if you start off by thinking well if
give a man or woman a fish is here and
teach them to fish is here so they can
have a livelihood that's the beginning
of a hierarchy of response but given
what we heard today that in 40 years
there won't be any more fish it changes
the way you think about that and what if
you gave someone the ability to fish but
there was no market that they could then
sell their fish or their neighbor
couldn't grow any rice to swap with them
so they could have a healthy diet or
there's no export industry that allowed
them to bring their fish to market so
they could earn the goods and services
they could educate their children and
you can start thinking like something
other than you thought a philanthropist
would think and the way Google is
structured I have the opportunity many
of my colleagues are here with me and we
have the opportunity to think
differently than the traditional
philanthropy in the sense of making
donations or grants we can think like
that
we can think that what we would like to
do is to create a hundred thousand jobs
in Africa and what would that take I was
talking earlier with Richard that in the
old days you might think if you have a
hundred million dollars and you give
that as philanthropy to help create jobs
that's a great thing to do whereas if
you were a businessman
and you invested money and you lost
money that would be a terrible thing to
do but actually it's the opposite
because if you wanted to put a hundred
million dollars to use in Africa and you
gave it as grants you would then create
dependency you would create inflation in
wages but if you took a billion dollars
and you invested it in Africa and you
lost a hundred million dollars you got
back 900 million you would have put a
hundred million dollars to work but that
billion dollars of investment would have
created roads and schools and
electricity and jobs that were
sustainable and good and kids who could
go to school so what I've learned I
think in the six months since I've
coming in the five months since you had
that wonderful workshop for us to
introduce us all to the world of
philanthropy what I've learned is that
it's not the way I thought it was before
when all of us together months or years
how many times we've all been together
and we had a beer or we smoked something
other than a cigarette and we said if
only I had X dollars here's how I would
change the world that changes a little
bit when you're put in a position where
now you really have X dollars and it's
it's a very humbling experience there
are no textbooks to go to there are a
few wise people to go and talk to the
challenges are enormous the opportunity
is staggering it's very humbling and I
just want to end end by saying one thing
we are all in it together
it's not the person who writes the check
it's not the person who has the 501 C 3
it's not the philanthropist it's not the
government it's not the people
elect the government we are now facing
as Catherine said so many simultaneous
crises the crisis in the environment the
climate crisis the staggering disparity
between rich and poor
to an extent that's never been seen
before in the world 3.5 billion people
have cell phones three billion people
can't afford to place a single phone
call 1.2 billion people don't have
enough water and can't consume enough
calories to maintain their body weight
in India there are 300 million people
who live on less than a dollar a day and
they live in the shadows of Bombay where
there are more billionaires than there
are in New York City there are thirty
novel communicable diseases that have
emerged in the last thirty years that
come about because we've destroyed our
rainforest because we voted the green
belt between animals and humans because
we raised more protein than ever before
30 years ago the population of China was
1 billion today it's 1.35 billion a 35
percent growth rate but 35 years ago the
population of chickens in China was 12
million and today it's 15 billion we
have a chicken human interface problem
it should be no surprise that we're
seeing diseases of animals that are
jumping to humans we will face 10 years
from now a crises we're instead of
talking about fossil fuels we will be
talking about fossil water so these are
not problems that are going to go away
tomorrow we're not going to solve those
problems on this stage government's not
going to solve these problems alone
academicians are not going to solve
these problems alone
you're engaged minds and hearts or
what's going to solve this problem and
we are literally all in this together
and I think that's what I've learned in
the last six months okay before we get
too
before we get to good questions coming
in from the audience I want to give
Richard you first and Larry a shot at
asking you've seen Katherine's condensed
version of her for our presentation just
now what questions do you have of her
Katherine as a result of my own
evolution of sort of going from
unconsciousness to consciousness about
philanthropy I've also thought about the
thing that is that the route at least of
traditional philanthropy which is money
itself and there are many aspects of
that to consider obviously the cash
economy but also as you mentioned Larry
the disparity between rich and poor one
of the difficulties that I have with
philanthropy at the the philanthropy
that everybody does or hopefully
everybody does is not a problem for me
so much but the philanthropy by really
wealthy people has a kind of built-in
blind spot related to the unintended
consequences of a the cash economy
itself but be even more so extreme
wealth great wealth when one consults to
works for wealthy people whether in even
when they're giving away their money one
is kind of tacitly saying that's okay to
have all of that money in the first
place
and I just wonder how you because you
spend a lot of your life in consulting
to folks who have got a lot of money how
do you deal with that and if you're able
to not make it a blind spot for yourself
or the and particularly the inequalities
of wealth how do you make it how do you
put it out there and deal with it
it's a it's a great question I think
that one of the tragedies for people who
have great wealth is their isolation and
it's you know it's one of those things
where you can't complain about having a
lot of resource given what's going on in
the world but I think that there are
there there are tremendous problems for
people who have great wealth and the
only thing that I can say to people is
do everything possible to overcome that
isolation and I think that means going
out and seeing things yourself and and
then if you cannot or will not it's the
thing I was talking about and it was
almost less shorthand I couldn't really
explain is the the disconnect I see
between people who make decisions and
where the knowledge rests and so and and
I think that the you either have to
overcome it in your own heart and
yourself or you have to have the wisdom
to put that put the decision-making in
the hands of people who will but I it is
it is nevertheless true that all those
numbers I put up there are results of
growing inequity it's the other side of
it and so all I can figure out is how do
we turn that into a positive and and and
help to help to create change from it
but it's there's a lot of people who
look at the soul of money and the
relationship of money to people's
psychology and and in spirit and all you
can do is bear witness to that and help
people and encourage people to to go out
in the world as obviously you have Larry
what's your question
what sort of a comment I guess which is
that of all the tools that we have in in
doing social activism money is the least
of those tools in my experience ideas
passion sort of a magical belief in the
impossible but those are much more
important than money I've watched the
smallpox eradication program succeed
I've been involved in the tsunami and in
so many disasters what what has I think
what highlights the successes hasn't
been the well financed once the over
resourced ones it's been the ones in
which the people who you were working
side-by-side with had eyes that were
ablaze and you felt like you were part
of a team that was almost part of the
soldiers of light fighting against the
soldiers of darkness and I guess that
leads into my question which is you
you've described philanthropy and
philanthropist almost like islands and
even in answering right now you're you
talked about the loneliness of wealthy
ins that's what wavy calls rich people
wealthy ins you know like Atlanteans
wealthy and but but the real real
strength is when all of us are together
and we're in it together so how how do
you perform that magic on the community
of people with good hearts strong hands
and good resources how how do all of us
bring together the Gates's and the
Rockefellers and the Google
the Omid er's in the schools and focus
our efforts on the crises of our time
and how do we protect ourselves from the
kind of the dripping out the drip drip
drip out of not just the resources but
the energy and the excitement and the
activism how do we build a community of
all of us individual donors and
philanthropists the bigger
philanthropist how does that community
set its mind as a single unity to solve
the great problems of our times and he
expects me to answer the question well
you've answered it yourself I mean by
asking it you that is the single when I
said that it's about being connected and
thinking long-term I to me the question
is how do you set the how do we set a
goal I mean so it's a question it's
almost like how can you we how can we
get a campaign mentality that what
brings people together across you know
from from many differences is a common
goal whether it's eradicate smallpox or
something else and so I think that the
but the question is that the problem is
campaigns are short and a lot of this
stuff has got to be long and so I think
that it's going to require some you know
if if in fact the foundation was
invented you know because your
great-grandfather couldn't figure out it
give all his money away his lifetime and
said in fact we need to you know so he
literally they change the laws and
fatten you know who's created the
foundation form maybe we need to figure
out how to create some sort of vehicle
that that is that serves the purpose of
a campaign but doesn't go away so it's
it's something about every organization
is making its strategy by itself so
Google makes its strategy in a Midler
makes its strategy and Gates makes its
strategy and the things that people do
come together on is something where
there's a common goal
that's but I think the question you ask
is exactly the the one and the reason I
tried really hard in this talk to make
this about all of us not about just the
people who you know the magazine covers
are about there I've got a question here
it is part answer to that I think builds
on what Katherine are saying Kevin Kelly
is likening the questions here so this
question has be from Kevin Kelly he
probably eats the icing first too given
the tremendous mountains of time energy
poured into the creation and maintenance
of Wikipedia we had Jimmy Wales talking
here a couple months ago and he said the
design of Wikipedia is the design of
community would you call this enterprise
new philanthropy and what might it teach
us about giving effort rather than money
I would definitely call it yeah also
it's question is what will people do
that for you know the great I've been in
a lot of conversations about open-source
philanthropy and you know that what is
it that people will you know one of the
great stories and it's one of the
thousands of things were in my notes
that you'll be happy I didn't have to
have a time to test say but you know one
of the great stories of after Katrina
was the software engineers who came
together voluntarily and figured you
remember how everybody was looking for
their family and there was an NBC
database and there was this there were
all these databases and the software
Jews came to figure out how to put them
all together so you could you know it so
that you weren't having to you know go
here and here and here and here and here
so the question is so what is it that
will that people will volunteer for
there's a taxonomy or starting to pay
attention to here
Wikipedia has this quality that it
scales that it has this persistence and
it has this community it has this focus
Burning Man is another one of these
phenomena that seems to keep scaling and
has this persistence and focuses
community cities have this quality
they've been at it for
10,000 years actually and that may be
these are at least three answers of the
kinds of things that have those two
things you're looking at community and
persistence can I also add a little bit
on that I'm not so sure what QP D is the
right model
I think Wikipedia is a great answer to a
different question okay when when the
when the tsunami he had I went to Intel
and I tried to get them to build a big
old matching engine so that anybody who
wanted to donate time and had skills or
donate money or donate resources could
be matched with people in one of the
countries that had suffered one kind of
calamity and I got frustrated and nobody
was giving me the big matching system I
want so I went myself to Indonesia and
the Sri Lanka but now that I've come
back I can tell you that there are at
least a dozen such software systems that
are being developed right now Catherine
talked about a couple of them give India
being one of them but there's a lot more
and they really look a lot more like
eBay without the buying and selling
they're swapping and matching services
and wouldn't it be great if match.com
didn't mean find sex online but if
match.com meant find a way to fill your
heart with the generosity of spirit and
find something that you could do that
really made a big difference and and I
think I'm beginning to see some things
like that there's something called Kiva
where individuals can make small micro
loans in the Grameen Bank model to
projects that you've never met or heard
about are very far away and you
literally would say I want to find a
woman with a bicycle repair shop in
Kenya and Wow there's a woman with a
bicycle repair shop in Kenya wants one
hundred dollar loan and you directly
make that mic
alone I can see things like that arising
that provide a way to take the entire
power of the philanthropy for the rest
of us and put it in service of those
needs Stuart can I please just say
something to that too is was one of the
things I might have said about learnings
but I'll I'll put it in here I think for
my money so to speak
I like the Wikipedia example because I
think what makes Wikipedia work and last
is that it is about reciprocity if you
put something in you get something back
and I think that that's true about the
micro loans as well by the way it's not
a one-way thing nobody's having charity
done to them and volunteer programs are
notoriously short-lived because people
go in for a certain purpose if there's a
very close link between power relations
and and volunteerism and power relations
and charity people get what they need
out of it but they are not but the
people who have the charity done to them
have no chance to give back and the
people yet who are who are doing the
charity work fulfill that need and they
move on to the next thing there's a much
deep and by the way Maimonides what he
did say was the highest good is to give
without expectation of return and it was
he then in the in the Middle Ages who
got us on to this track that in fact we
should be doing charity to other people
and he it was useful in many respects
but it kind of got us off track from a
deeper motivation and a longer-lasting
are one that's instinctual built in
which is not pure altruism but
reciprocity and community I think what
what our new technologies are able to do
money has removed its neutralized
reciprocity in a way you translate
everything into money and it comes out
on the other side with no human relation
you just pay the money and you get the
object I think we we are on the verge of
having a new kind of currency that
allows reciprocity through the through
the technology
self and thereby reenact reactivating
the the motivations to be in reciprocal
relationship that's why in one way I
asked about money
money itself has really dark sides to it
and what I hope is that philanthropy
maybe we won't call it that anymore
we'll be moving towards something that
is much more reciprocal and moves us in
a way that we can sustain okay there's a
[Music]
there's two themes that have emerged in
the questions I'm seeing and the social
secretary after all is this sort of
newcomer to what had been in the past
all private sector and public sector
government in business and Paul Hawken
in relation to the business end of it
asks variable thank you do you think it
makes sense to use business parlance
entrepreneur markets mutual funds social
profits as a way to describe generosity
and kindness wouldn't it be more helpful
if the metaphors went the other way you
mean that we were talking about kindness
and business themes that's the main one
is what you were noting and what we see
here on the stage actually is that most
of the money that's coming into the
social sector is coming straight from
business it came with your great
grandfather came with Carnegie it's
coming from Google that's the the
Harwich the DNA the lineage that comes
with the money and you pointed out that
the the new a lot of the new money is
high tech money and certain things come
with that well it's a it's it is a great
question and it I would love to have a
conversation with you about that Paul
it's I have really struggled a lot with
the language and metaphor systems here
because I actually think the the the big
trend toward talking about philanthropy
as investment is
[Music]
it has the problem that you pointed out
but it also has the promise is not
actually right I mean it's actually you
don't make an investment for a you know
it's it's the metaphor actually doesn't
work my colleague Andrew Blau wrote a
great paper of it it's actually much
more like the consumer relationship than
it is than it is an investment
relationship but but I will just tell
you a brief story of I think it's also
this whole thing it's not just the
language system but the way we talk
about philanthropy is very American and
one of the great moments in my life in
the last ten years and my journey to
learn about all of this I was in a room
with people much people from around the
world and there was this Italian guy and
I was doing my American thing of you
know philanthropy is is something that's
trying to make you know something happen
in the world right it's it's the
strategic philanthropy it's the the
frame in which I was talking and and and
he just looked over me he said that's
[ __ ] he said philanthropy is about
saving my soul and it was just a very
interesting you know very interesting
comeuppance to get you know you know
it's it's so I I think that it's it's
there is a great deal of energy around
this language system because it does
come out of business and it is something
we should we should ask some questions
about okay another theme then is
relation to public sector and basically
the a lot of the slides that you showed
in your video I had this kind of social
justice angle of what you were talking
about Larry
government good government has checks
and balances in it and the question here
from several questioners Chris greens is
Chris Cruz sorry as part of its Andy
Cohen as part of it that Stuart Gans as
part of it is is the philanthropic world
the social sector part of the checks and
balances of government speaking truth to
power and things like that does it have
its own checks and balances business has
all kinds of checks and balances like
fail and go out of business oh where
does all this fit together start with
you Katherine
I think to me that there are two levels
that that operates at to me civil
society and the real actor to me is
civil society with philanthropy as part
of that in the support of that is is one
of the only stalwarts we have against
abuse of power by government so to me
it's fundamentally part of the part of
the system and in fact I spent many
years as a journalist and I'm more and
more concerned you know in terms of
what's happening to the media and press
in this country I think we in 10 or 20
years could be in a place where some of
the traditional role that the media
played in terms of holding government to
account will no longer be played by the
media will have to be played can I fix
by philanthropy by the way what's that
can that be fixed by philanthropy
business isn't helping much i I think
you know I have believed for a long time
that some of the great journalism in the
future will be owned by and run by
nonprofits and in fact I tried to get
one of my newspaper clients to sell
their newspaper and set up a foundation
to do that but they didn't do that but
but I think that the other part of the
question is equally important so you
know in my belief system civil society
isn't very much about
it's speaking truth to power the problem
is it's very hard to speak truth to
philanthropy and and it's it's I mean
anybody who's ever worked in the system
or around it knows that that what I'm
saying is true
and there are no natural feedback loops
in philanthropy and there are people who
are trying to work on that in a variety
of ways but you know soon reflect
reflect Center for effective
philanthropy is just the very early step
of doing things like grantee surveys and
giving ways to give blind feedback to
foundations it's a small it's a small
step but in my thinking about this I
think that it really comes down to the
so why I talked about the ethical system
and enlarging the the empathy of the of
the person it's some philanthropies
voluntary if you pressure philanthropy
or if you set too many regulations and
government and you set too many rules
people just say fine I'll just go away
you know so I think it's a really
complicated problem how we get
philanthropy to be more accountable so
okay that's part of what the the rest of
new philanthropy is gonna need to solve
because it's not a place yet you're
right that's right
do you guys have further under
inspection I just said the the rest of
the new philanthropy is even less
accountable the old the old philanthropy
had time to create expectations and
expectations make actions accountable
against historical precedents the new
philanthropy because it's new and it has
tried to evade the restrictions of the
501c3 or the foundations or the 5% rules
or any of these other strictures it is
it is even more unbounded and more
experimental and it'll be very
interesting to see how it develops
but I do think that there's a different
kind of a check-and-balance I guess of
sorts between philanthropy and
government because I've always thought
thought that the world is governed by
God and anecdotes I mean good stories
success stories
once you've accomplished something
whether it is with a model in
philanthropy or civil society it's
really hard to put that genie back in
the bottle the reason that so many of us
have fought against the war in Iraq and
believed that we would ultimately win
was because we saw the war in Vietnam
stopped we hadn't seen that and had that
in the back of our minds or for the
young people here in the backs of your
history books we wouldn't have the
courage I think to fight against the
government because in history the people
never fought against the government's
that went to war so the anecdotes will
drive us in philanthropy and civil
society give us the Martin Luther King's
and the Nelson Mandela's and they give
us aspirational figures and goals and I
hope that never stops you got it
I before I took over as chair of
Rockefeller Brothers fund which just
happened quite recently I chaired a kind
of an ad-hoc committee on our
accountability and and sort of quality
control whatever you want to call it
within the organization we looked at
what other foundations had done one of
the things that was extraordinary to me
was that Robert Wood Johnson a very
large Eastern Foundation spent twenty
million dollars trying to do a valuation
of their own program unbelievable amount
of money and when I looked at what what
they learned
I was unimpressed a lot of it is what
you if we sat around here for a few
minutes and wrote down how we thought we
would account for what we were doing in
foundations we would come up with it
right off the bat and then you in the
end when you go about scoring it you
don't know what to do with the score is
you can't maximize more than one
independent variable and so you come up
with a lot of things that you think you
should be doing and in the end of the
day you don't you can't say and that's
by the way why first of all why when
businesspeople get into it they think
why it shouldn't be so complicated
because they've been in a scoring system
that has one independent variable and
you can maximize it it's the bottom line
but you can't do that when you get into
philanthropy at all and so I with saying
all that there's no point saying a whole
lot more I've thought about it a great
deal it's damned hard to get appropriate
accountability within the foundation and
the not-for-profit sector and you have
to keep trying because you can't not be
accountable but we don't have so
government has got Gaudin anecdotes I
mean that is what they thrive on and the
business community has got the bottom
line and we don't have anything nearly
so neat as any of those so I don't know
that's true well that's the question I'm
going away from here tonight well come
down to the the last question though
Katherine your presentation this is from
Larry Hammel your presentation didn't
have much about religious donations and
how they work and what's going on there
you said I think you said it's declining
a bit but it's enormous and just gives
us some of the kind of insight you gave
about all the rest and about that domain
if you know well I think that like a lot
of things it's it's not one thing it's
many things right so the money that is
that that gets religion against it in
the in the reports and the tax codes
some of that money is goes to support
churches and synagogues and mosques and
that to me is the type of philanthropy
that is really more about getting a tax
deduction for funding your own community
I mean it's it's a it is a it is a
community and it's of a benefit to you
and then there is the type of money that
goes and religious cause that goes out
into the world and does many wonderful
things and I think the the evangelical
community for instance have been very
involved in the campaign on the genocide
in Darfur and so I think that a lot of
the religious money that is outside the
the more institutional supports falls
minook at it like the other types of
money that's trying to have an impact
and is flowing in different ways and
have they been separated out
statistically you know it's not that I'm
sure that by by various denominations
and those you could probably do it but
the money the the gross statistics that
are available don't separate it out and
then of course every church gives money
be very hard to one of the things about
philanthropy is it's unknowable
right you know every time you think you
you know something mean it's thousands
of institutions and its actions all the
time you know and so it's a it's a it's
a it's a very large domain as large as
humanity itself there you had some done
that it look like on the religious
question religious money I mean you've
been at it with a lot of the slums and
and there's a lot of really close to the
ground church work going on there
Pentecostal crust I can tell all sorts
hopes and whatnot all sorts of stories
during the tsunami saver foundation
there are many people here from saiva
we started receiving donations to work
in Indonesia and we sent we tried to
find the organizations to work with in
Indonesia and we finally found the
absolute best organization to work with
and it was called Islamic charities
Islamic relief of Indonesia
and we did send money to Islamic Relief
of Indonesia and of course that
immediately brought the government
looking at what we were doing because
they had a search engine looking for
anybody giving money to Islamic Relief
anybody who's worked in Africa knows
that the best the hardest working and
the most effective charity are done by
the churches when when I first came to
Google Google's got a program where
nearly 2,000 nonprofits get free
advertising and support raising money
and we give hundreds of millions of
dollars a year to those organizations
but we're very concerned about the
fungibility of that money if it goes to
a religious organization does it go for
the purpose of being religiously
motivated relief or does it go to the
purpose of conversions and for for
changes in religious but when you watch
what happens in Africa you you couldn't
say I'm not going to give any money to
religious organizations and yet I'm
going to help support aid work in Africa
you would have a very small group of
people to work with
Richard you have a perspective on that
I'm not I guess I mean what occurs to me
is you're talking I haven't thought
about this before but you're the quote
from Stuart that used earlier about not
being able to see over the horizon of
our death this is why we don't take the
future personally I think that's one of
the reasons that religious organizations
can persist because they have a meme
that allows them to see over that
horizon and and experience themselves
there unfortunately from my point of
view as a rather enthusiastic atheist it
comes with a lot of virulence and other
stuff that that is not helpful so what
I'm pondering here is what can we do to
substitute that long horizon meme with
something that that isn't so well what
whatever adjectives you want to put in
there but I don't know I love the
concept of a rather enthusiastic atheist
especially given you know but the word
enthusiasm is made up which is embracing
a God as you all know I write up
summaries these talks afterwards and
Larry Hammel asked question said what I
put in at this time - a report on
whether the contents of the donation box
was any different with this talk
[Laughter]
thank you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you